una capa de hielo bajo la que fluye un
océano de agua salada líquida de al
menos 100 kilómetros de profundidad
Europa ganímedes y calisto las tres
lunas heladas de Júpiter parecen tener
los elementos necesarios para la vida la
Sonda europea Just va cartografiar estos
satélites que son tan grandes como
pequeños planetas y contienen más agua
que la tierra uno de los instrumentos
clave el espectrógrafo magis diseñado en
el instituto de astrofísica de zaclaya
al sur del país
es un instrumento que caracterizará la
composición del hielo y los diversos
compuestos de la superficie de los
satélites de Júpiter así como la
atmósfera las nubes y los aerosoles de
la atmósfera de Júpiter
la Sonda también estudiará el gigante
gaseoso su atmósfera su campo magnético
y sus anillos
el objetivo de la misión Just Es
realmente pasar a una nueva fase en el
estudio del sistema de Júpiter gracias a
instrumentos mucho más complejos con una
tecnología que ha progresado en los
últimos 20 años para la agencia espacial
europea que dirige el proyecto se trata
de una misión crucial Privada de
lanzador y de su socio ruso la esa se
juega parte de su credibilidad en esta
misión
[Música]
Es la primera vez que la agencia
espacial europea se adentra tanto en el
sistema solar también Es la primera vez
que orbitamos alrededor de una luna que
no es la nuestra y la primera vez que
vamos a realizar dos maniobras para
insertar ayus en el campo gravitatorio
al principio de Júpiter y después en el
campo gravitatorio de ganímedes
El despegue de Just a bordo de arian 5
está previsto para mediados de abril en
courou en la guayana francesa y las
primeras observaciones Se esperan para